[Music]
this morning on the dish and expert in
the ancient art of handmade pasta Evan
funky grew up in Southern California the
son of an oscar-winning special-effects
photographer but he looked to make his
magic with food after working with
Wolfgang Puck at the iconic Spago in
Beverly Hills he headed off to study
pasta making in Italy now his creations
are on the menu at his felix trattoria
in Venice California and just this week
he released his debut cookbook Americans
Foligno nice teaching did I get that
appreciate it
teaching readers how to make artisanal
pasta at home chef Evan funky good
morning thank you for having you the
dish we have what do we have yeah pasta
and what else so this is a simple rucola
salad you find anywhere in Italy here in
front of you the first pastas balance on
e this is a very interesting pasta and
the con Demento for that is a mixture of
super rowdy herbs brown butter over
there the quintessential Roman dish at
owner Willie Culpepper and then in the
middle here is tagliatelle Bolognese and
over there is a beautiful thank god
there's still tomatoes in New York
Yummie she's a panzanella with burrata
and this delicious-looking oh what is
this piece of business Saturday morning
so simple aperitif oh all right we use a
lot of Amaro's at at Felix and Oh kick
think we're not driving not the horse
whisperer but the pasta whisperer
coming from a family of filmmakers I
mean how did you delve into the world of
pasta well my family my entire family is
very artistic I was sent to to art
school very very young I played the
drums for 10 years my oldest brother is
a famous DJ my second oldest brother is
a composer placed 13 instruments all
self-taught chef and my sister worked in
fashion for quite some time and my
youngest brother actually designs
classic eyewear
but pasta for you is not it's not a food
it's a philosophy alright and it's
really informed everything about your
lacrima absolutely I'm much more
interested in the Anthropology behind
the shape not necessarily the the
technical aspect but the history and the
people connected to the shape because
any modern pasta that you'll find in the
grocery store has an ancestral shape
that was at one time made by a woman in
the house by her hands what's the most
interesting story of that oh there's
there's so many any pasta that's made it
to modern times has a story connecting
some myth and some more and that's why
it's made it to modern times because
it's so interesting like this Buffy
ballons Oni so this one is actually the
story goes that they serve this during
the carnevale it's named for dr. a
balanced Oni which he was a great right
he was a jack-of-all-trades he was a
student he was an author he was a
philosopher and a teacher as well so it
kind of mirrors what's inside a mixture
of everything and this obviously to me
tastes a lot different than the pasta
that I buy at the store so I think you
know how do you also get people to not
be intimidated by this art form that's
right there in that book got together
tried to break it up into very
digestible sequential aspects so that we
kind of demystify in Italy especially
Bologna they teach very very young
people very young ages six years old to
begin to start making pasta
unfortunately it's dying there's less
and less people who are interested in
practicing and carrying on the
traditions why do you think that is too
many distractions no cell phone Facebook
and violin practice and soccer and all
of that other things so back in the day
it was like you can't go outside until
you finish this cue of what I kept it
for dinner
so it was essential for life so I'm kind
of presenting myself as the godson for
all of these Nona to pass this
information off to me I'm dying to ask
you the big calorie question but we need
you out
it's your weekend right but if you
wanted to have this meal with anyone who
who would it be as you sign the dish
Bourdain Anthony Bourdain Bourdain
absolutely I never got to meet him he
was hugely impactful in my life very
very early on as a cook
what Kitchen Confidential came out it
was like what is this pirate society I
have to learn more obviously there's a
lot of it is you know no longer relevant
but and no longer acceptable well chef
we thank you for being here and thank
you so much for having me oh we're so
glad if you want to know more about the
chef and his dish or this dish head to
our website at CBS this morning calm
thank you so much